you are of course already on thin ice in
this culture if you make your own
decisions
and live your life according to values
that fall outside of the mainstream even
if you do this quietly in an unobtrusive
and unassuming way it'll still be
considered an affront to those who for
whatever reason
are personally offended by your personal
choices but if you god forbid
openly advocate for those values and
express satisfaction
with the choices that you've made then
you have really crossed the line crossed
the line at least in the minds of our
leftist cultural overlords
who have gone to great lengths to tell
us what our values should be
and what kind of life we should lead and
they do not appreciate having their
instructions so blatantly ignored
new york times opinion writer elizabeth
brunig discovered this fact over the
weekend in the lead up to mother's day
after writing a piece
on the subject of motherhood that
provoked great outrage on the left
especially among feminists
now we should note that brunig is no
right-wing radical she's certainly on
the left herself she's also
no fan of mine for the record she has a
long-standing and rather passionate
distaste for me in all of my opinions
this is kind of surprising as i'm
usually beloved by liberal women
in any case none of that saved brunig
from the blowback for the piece she
published with this
shocking title get ready for it the
title is
i became a mother at 25 and i'm not
sorry i didn't wait
provocative stuff at least provocative
for those who believe that women should
not say anything about motherhood
unless they're saying that they regret
being mothers or that they're happy they
never became mothers
like those are the two things that as a
woman you're allowed to say publicly
about motherhood
the piece as the title suggests is
simply all about brunic's decision to
become a mother at a comparatively young
age
and how and why she's happy that she did
it now of course 25
is not really a young age to have a
child back when your great-grandmother
was having babies
25 would have been considered downright
geriatric
to start the process but even today in
some circles
uh and even today in some circles 25 is
is not really young my wife was around
that age when when we had our first
child or children twins
but broadly speaking the average age for
marriage and for having children has
been rising dramatically in this country
for years now so now on average women
are waiting until
28 to get married and men until 30. of
course not everyone
gets married before having kids
unfortunately but this this is generally
the way things are trending
in in the circles that a liberal
cosmopolitan woman like brunig runs in
the age for marriage and children is
going to be probably considerably higher
even than that
so again from a comparative standpoint
25 is young
as for the article i have to admit even
though she hates my guts she writes kind
of beautifully uh here's here's one part
she says quote what i didn't understand
couldn't have at the time
was that deserting yourself for another
person really is a relief my days began
to unfold according to
her schedule that weird rhythm of
newborns
and the worries i entertained were
better than the ones that came before
more concrete more vital less tethered
to the claustrophobic confines of my own
skull
for this member of a generation famously
beset by anxiety it was a welcome
liberation
liberation she's talking about the
liberation of motherhood
which of course is the opposite of what
we so often hear that women are
liberated by
leaving the home leaving motherhood by
liberating even by killing their own
children
but she's taking the opposite
perspective and it's very well said and
what she says is profoundly true
but many on the left didn't feel that
way feminist writer and
miserable cat lady amanda marcotte said
that the piece was quote
naked pandering to the fantasies of
pathetic men
and further offering her thoughts she
wrote quote i would like to thank this
headline
byline combo for helping me set a record
for the quickest
gross pass i've ever uttered in my life
feminist author jude ellison sadie doyle
who looks exactly as you'd expect a
feminist author with four names to look
tweeted this the greatest trick the
devil ever pulled was convincing this
woman it was a tremendous personal
achievement to be repeatedly knocked up
by an internet troll that she met in
high school
another imagine imagine saying that in
response to
a woman writing something on mother's
day about how she's happy to be a mother
what you think it's an achievement to be
knocked up
my god these people are miserable
another blue check on twitter um jackie
shine
accused brunig of claiming that her life
decisions are superior to other peoples
and another
aurora bogato somehow found in the piece
evidence of quote white extinction
anxiety and there was plenty more where
all this came from but you get the idea
brunig expressed a point of view that
you're not supposed to express and this
was the reaction
for example for an example of the point
of view that you are supposed to express
the point of view that you are supposed
to have as a mother or a parent
here's feminist writer jill felopovich
also last week around the same time as
the hullabaloo over the brunig article
she tweeted this
i would really love to read more essays
and op-eds from women
and men too who regret having children
as early as they did regret having as
many as they did
or regret having children at all there's
not much about motherhood that remains
publicly unexplored but that does
yes regrets resentment misery
that's what jill flopovich would like to
hear from others
certainly about gratitude love happiness
or any other such
repulsive emotion and she wrote a longer
piece by the way explaining why she
tweeted that and and how this is a taboo
this is one of the last taboos in our
society for mothers to talk about their
regret
and uh and they we we should deconstruct
that taboo and
mother should be able to talk about this
of course it's actually not a taboo you
hear parents talk about their regrets
all the time
far too often but also by the way
one of the reasons
why you might not hear mothers saying
that aloud very often is first of all
most mothers don't regret having kids
and second if you do regret it like
that's probably the kind of thing you
shouldn't say publicly
because your kids are going to read that
one day and maybe you don't want to
announce to the whole world hey i regret
having this human right here now
i think there are two general points to
be made
about the the overall issue here first
of all
it is indeed a good idea to start a
family while young that's a good idea
i don't think that elizabeth brunig was
necessarily
pitching this as a as a strategy for
everyone but she was just talking about
her own choices
i will pitch it though i do think it's i
think it's a generally speaking a good
idea
again general statement it's not going
to be true in every single case
there are also many examples of people
both women and men who very much
wanted to have a family earlier in life
but were unable to for one reason or
another
nobody suggesting that you're doomed to
a life of pointless misery if you have
kids at 34
or if you never have them at all we're
simply talking about or at least i'm
talking about
general principles and as a general
principle it is better
to have a society where young parenthood
is the norm rather than the exception
that is better
why well for one biology
i know we don't care much for biology
these days but it does matter it's a
reality
the prime child bearing years for women
are between around
the age of 20 and up to about 34 or 35
give or take a year to on either end
once a woman is out of those prime years
the um the chance of miscarriage of
health complications with the mother or
child etc
go way up a woman's body a woman's body
seems to have an opinion about when
women should be having kids and that
opinion differs
from the career first priorities of
modern society
also it's good for marriage and family
to be the foundation of adult life
rather than the capstone see these days
we have this idea
that we ought to get married and have
kids once we have all of our other
affairs in order and all of our
finances straightened out and we're out
we've already bought the house and we've
done all that
we've established our adult existence
and then we fit a family
into that already pre-established mold
now this can it's it sounds maybe
intuitively like it makes sense to do
things this way
but it could cause major problems
especially in a marriage
because now there's a feeling that
you're bringing someone into this thing
that you've already built without them
you've been an adult for a long time
you've lived your whole life without
this person
you've done all of this that all of this
was was you didn't need their help for
it
and now you're bringing them into it
the children too you're bringing into
this thing that has been long since
established before they ever showed up
they become
or they can seem like intruders
more so than partners in the journey now
in my case getting married and starting
a family younger
all that we have now and we've built
we've done together my wife and i we
walk the journey of young adulthood
together as a team
moreover there's something to be said i
think for having kids
when you still have the physical energy
to keep up with them
boys especially need a dad who can run
around wrestle
pick them up toss them in the air climb
into trees to rescue them when they've
climbed too high and so on the great
thing is that when you have children
young
you can do all that stuff with them and
you may even be able to do some of that
some of it with your grandchildren if my
kids have kids when i did i'll be in my
mid-50s when grandchildren arrive on the
scene
if those kids have kids at the same age
then i'll be around to see my
great-grandchildren
though i'll probably be as mentally
present and cognizant as joe biden by
then but still i'll be there
the point is younger marriage and
parenthood means multi-generational
families it means
kids who get to grow up with parents
grandparents and great grandparents
so having kids young pays dividends in
the long run
but you have to care about the long run
you have to be able to look outside of
the immediate
you have to have priorities that go
beyond comfort and convenience in this
present fleeting moment because it is
certainly true
while there's a lot of joy to be found
in having a family
um it is oftentimes not very comfortable
and it's certainly not convenient it is
never the most convenient thing
your life will will become no part of
your life will become more convenient
once you have kids
that's for sure in fact very many things
that you didn't even think about before
now become a thing they become an issue
um they become even a source potentially
of conflict
that's how it is to have kids
but underneath all of that is the joy
waiting to be
found and felt and explored and that
brings us to the second point
you know that's what makes left-wingers
and feminists so upset i think
because their operating principle their
priority
is to maximize surface level pleasure
in each moment as each moment passes you
say to yourself
how can i feel the most comfortable
and feel the most immediate pleasure in
this moment
and then you do whatever you need to do
for that
the problem is that this strategy has
rapidly diminishing returns
whereas the deeper joy of family life
can increase with age
i mean just talk to uh someone who just
recently became a grandparent
and then the joy that they experienced
there
and they'll leave they'll tell you that
it's it's it's not that it's
better than being a parent but it's a
new kind of joy that they had never
experienced before
so the joys can increase with age and
also
that decision to have a family while
young reaps new rewards
at each stage of life
the pleasure of living a life consumed
only by your own personal immediate
satisfaction
and material gain tends on the other
hand to fade over time and i think
this is why feminists only get more and
more bitter
as they age you look at someone like
amanda marcotte or
jill felipovich or any of these
feminists have been on the scene for a
long time
and you look at their writing they've
just gotten angrier and angrier as they
get older
because they're lonely and miserable and
they realize
that their approach to life has failed
them
and they and it is envy they look like
someone like elizabeth brunic
made a different decision is
experiencing the joy of that
and it makes them envious and hateful
if they can't have joy then they don't
want you to have it either
it really is as simple as that for them
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content